Cuál es el principal legado o logro del
presidente mexicano hasta este momento
qué tal Valentina Buenas noches a ti y a
tu auditorio efectivamente como bien lo
comentabas el presidente entra en Este
quinto año de gobierno marcado por la
polarización
y lo inauguró este pasado domingo con un
desfile
en donde desde luego con una gran
convocatoria y y es muestra principal de
la polarización que se vive en este en
este país este desfile fue organizado en
respuesta a una convocatoria
movilización ciudadana a nivel
del estado al Instituto Nacional
electoral que el presidente Busca
suprimir mediante una reforma
constitucional poco probable pero por
otro lado como bien lo señalas otras
deudas importantes en términos de
seguridad justamente durante las
campañas el presidente prometió retirar
a las fuerzas armadas de las calles para
tareas de seguridad pública y y no
solamente no lo hizo sino que lo ha
reforzado
y ello avalado por la suprema corte de
justicia de la nación que avaló su
constitucionalidad entre otras cosas que
además de la gravedad de la decisión en
sí misma pues desde luego ha generado
fuertes cuestionamientos respecto de la
independencia del poder judicial
bueno Y si de alguna manera lo ponemos
en positivo cuál podría considerarse su
mayor logro su mayor legado hasta este
momento
bueno él tiene el presidente sigue con
goza de una buena aprobación entre la
población mencionabas tú
sesenta y cinco por ciento de acuerdo a
algunas mediciones pero justo el día de
hoy publica El Financiero otra medición
que lo coloca Aproximadamente en el
cincuenta y cinco por ciento que es tan
solo por encima de El presidente Peña
Nieto su su antecesor que para entrado
el sujeto año de gobierno gozaba con
apenas por encima del veinte por ciento
es decir es una aprobación alta con
algunas decisiones importantes justo hoy
mencionaba aumentos en el salario mínimo
a partir de el año que entra y y algunas
otras medidas populares tiene desde
luego un amplio catálogo de programas
sociales
con un con un padrones amplios de
beneficiarios sin embargo pues desde
luego estos también han generado fuertes
cuestionamientos en torno a la
transparencia y y a la eficacia de estos
programas sociales que no resuelven
concretamente problemas de la pobreza
como bien mencionabas hace unos momentos
Cómo se espera que sea su último año en
la administración
bueno Valentina Esta es una excelente
pregunta y lo que yo te podría comentar
al respecto es que vamos a seguir viendo
una fuerte polarización el presidente
está
tomando acciones importantes para seguir
concentrando poder en miras hacia el
2024 que se elige a nuestro próximo
presidente o presidenta eh Ya sus
correligionarios tienen tienen sus a sus
candidatos a sus candidatas fuera de los
tiempos electorales eh viajando por todo
el país haciendo en actos proselitistas
y en una buena medida se puede afirmar
que su último año de gobierno va a estar
concentrado en temas electorales yo te
comentaba Hace unos momentos sus
intenciones de reformar el Instituto
Nacional electoral autoridad Autónoma
del estado mexicano dedicada a la
organización de las elecciones y lo va
lograr lo pudiera lograr mediante
algunas reformas legales pero estaremos
por ver si esta batalla la logra llevar
mucho más adelante